[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter hello martin you look
very
cheerful today i am very cheerful
yes yes i'm glad you're cheerful because
the world looks
like it's in turmoil right yes but i'm
cheerful
because once you open your day
and you study the word of god and you
let him in
then you've got another focus in your
day yes then we can
deal with some of the knocks better than
we would without it but even then
sometimes the knocks
knocking off your feet right and then
you have to go back to then you have to
go back
get your take jesus's hand let's open
with the word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together thank you for
keeping us and thank you for
for warning the world our day we ask
that you
bless the viewers bless us and enlighten
our minds in jesus name amen
amen so what are we doing today martin
we've got a few questions but normally
it looks like when we've got a question
it becomes a whole lecture well
so it's not intentional it happens that
way and that's what i also
that's what i want to make clear to the
viewers we've got the questions here but
we never dictate how it's going to go
so if we answer one question if it takes
all what's up prof to do one question
then that's it if it if we answer four
questions yes
then we'll that will that's how it will
be it's absolutely
impossible to actually
do this at all in your own strength you
can't
because you don't even know where it's
going no
you don't even know where it's coming
from exactly and you're running around
at such a speed and there's so much
information that comes in how do you
filter that
it's impossible it's impossible if it
even
everything that has to do with what's
happening
in this studio or in other ministry
everything is so run and led by the holy
spirit
because no human being can do this can
do this we are
so dependent absolutely dependent
i don't i don't ever want to lose my
dependence i would be
so scared yes oh no so
let's see where this let's see where it
leads us
i'll ask a question adventists teach
that
in the catholic bible the ten
commandments were altered by eliminating
the second commandment
altering the fourth commandment and
dividing the tenth commandment into two
but in the douay rhymes bible they are
basically the same
how do we reconcile that well it's very
simple
adventists have never said that they've
changed it in the bible
they've changed it in the catechism yes
so if you read your catholic catechism
then you will see
that the sequence is different
even if you take the lutheran bible
even in the lutheran bible the ten
commandments are
like they are in the bible but you must
remember that
luther was a roman catholic priest
before he became
a protestant right so if you take the
catechism
of the lutheran bible the commandments
are basically there but the tenth
commandment
and the ninth commandment are reversed
from the catholic edition
so we must look at what the church
teaches as opposed to what the bible
teaches
of course in the catholic bible there
are many many verses
also that have been changed and the
jewel rhymes
which was a counter bible to the
reformation
bible there are many many verses
that are changed and of course
they also include the apocryphal books
and they make mary the mediator in the
great promise
of redemption i will put enmity between
thee
and the woman and then it is she that
crushes the head as we have said before
so there are many many distortions
in the juay rhymes bible for example
but they have the ten commandments
correct
but not in their catechism yes and just
for clarity
they put the catechism actually above
the bible yes because
according to catholic doctrine it is
tradition that determines the context of
scripture
and not scripture that determines
tradition
tradition yes thank you
does the bible and the spirit of
prophecy give us any more details about
when the day of probation ends i know
the seven last plagues are after
probation ends
and right before christ returns but what
about not
being able to buy and sell is that
before or after the close of probation
will these plagues be universal or will
it only affect certain countries or
places
well we do not know exactly
when probation closes there is no
indication in the bible that
gives us any time specifically
when probation closes but it gives us
clues it tells us what the events will
be
and buying and selling comes before
the implementation of the mark of the
base
now obviously if there is a warning
against the mark of the beast
and its acceptance and buying and
selling comes before that
then buying and selling is before the
close of probation yes
so first comes the buying and selling
then comes the mark of the beast
and then comes the loud cry against
accepting the mark of the beast which is
revelation chapter 18
and the call to come out of babylon yes
so that's the sequence
as we discussed in one of the previous
what's up profs
uh we are probably now
in that stage where the system
to control buying and selling is being
put into place
and implemented in the world yes very
rapidly
very rapidly very rapidly and once that
system
is in place then you will have the means
to manipulate people
to accept whatever else they throw at
you all these add-ons
and that one of the add-ons or the final
add-on
will be the implementation of enforced
sunday keeping and
then the part of the seven lost plagues
uh-huh
will the seven last plagues be universal
if they were
all of humanity would be destroyed so
they will be
in different places and at different
times
after after the close of probation
thank you so we will only know that
probation has closed
once the first plague falls correct
because there will also be a short
period of time
for probation to close after the sunday
legislation
absolutely because people must make a
decision they must make an informed
decision
and there will be a loud cry and the
loud cry
will be under the most adverse
conditions
and people will be aware that there
are people on this earth who
are willing to sacrifice their own
lives for the sake of this truth that
must make people think
because there will be a decree you won't
be able to buy or sell
there will be a decree that if you do
not go along with this
you'll get the death sentence and if
people say
i'd rather have the death sentence then
go along with it
then many people will think but you know
we've heard this before
and now it's actually happening could
these people be right
and perhaps they will study the
scripture and decide
but god said it's the seventh day
and it is the sign of his authority as
opposed to the authority of the world
so who is the world to enforce something
that is contrary to god's word
and they will make a decision hopefully
yes and come out of
my people that is the whole
object of the exercise amen
okay so let's see what else we've got
why when jesus is in galilee does the
scripture say he is going
up to jerusalem when he is clearly going
south
i notice this is consistent throughout
the world
well just for interest sake i'm always
at loggerheads of my wife
are we going up to
let's say durbin when you're living in
the cape or are you going
down are you reckoning it by sea level
or are you reckoning it on a map
on a map and that makes it very
confusing
but besides that there's a very
interesting analogy in the bible
no matter where you come from it always
says that you went
up to jerusalem and if you left
jerusalem you went
down and that has besides the
geographical
sea level application because jerusalem
is on a hill
right okay besides that application
it also has a spiritual application
when you go to god you are always up
it's a ladder and christ is the ladder
and he encourages you to go up so you
can never go
down to jerusalem you can only go
up to jerusalem in fact if you were on
mount everest you'd still be going
up to jerusalem because you would have
to go down into the valley and then go
up to jerusalem so no matter what you do
you will go up to jerusalem
but you know martin when
you said that this was one of the
questions i
immediately thought of the parable of
the good samaritan
because the parable of the good
samaritan
deals with this question of up and down
in in various contexts and i thought
perhaps you know
yeah i know i know it's not directly in
the question but
it is part of the question so i thought
as an example
we should actually look at the parable
and see where the up and the down
is in this in this issue
so if we go to luke chapter 10
jesus is telling the parable and he says
and behold a certain lawyer stood up
and tempted him saying master
what shall i do to inherit eternal life
and he said unto him what is written in
the law
how readest thou and he answering said
that thou
shalt love the lord thy god with all thy
heart
and with all thy soul and with all thy
strength and with all thy mind and thy
neighbor
as thyself and he said unto him thousand
answers
write this do and thou shalt live
so here is this expert
in the law of god and he is trying to
trip up jesus yes yeah you know this was
their favorite game
i don't know why they never learned that
they lost everything around
yeah they were trying to catch him out
every time and they could never do it
right should we pay taxes you know
if he if he says yes you should pay
taxes then
the pharisees will go crazy and if he
says no then the romans will go crazy so
we're going to trip him up
either way he's going to get it wrong
right and then
no no he has a coin whose head is on
this whose face is on that
run down to caesar what is due unto
caesar and unto god
what is due unto god checkmate yeah
they don't have anything nothing so in
any case
this is a very interesting introduction
because again we have the law of moses
which is the first five
books of the of the bible and then very
specifically
you have the summary of the ten
commandments
which is you shall love god
and you shall love your fellow men
on this hang on
the law and the prophets right no not
this replaces the law correct
so this is the summation of all things
and when he quoted the summary
of what it means to obey and
love god then jesus said to him thus
answered right this do
and thou shalt live now the next
question would be
okay how. good question
it's always the question right
but he willing to justify himself said
unto jesus
who is my neighbor
that's interesting right yeah and uh
even cain said am i my brother's keeper
fact of the matter is he is his
brother's keeper
we are all our brothers keeper we've got
that same question still today
this these questions don't go away and
who's my neighbor
and who is my brother and is there a
difference between the brother and the
neighbor
yes the brother is in the church
the brother is in the church and you
have to treat him
differently to what you treat someone
outside the church
for example in the bible you were
allowed to
ask usury of someone out of the church
yeah but you weren't allowed to have
usury in other words
interest for someone in the church
correct
so the way you treated them is is
different right even the way you treat
them
if though you see something that's not
right
yes correct so
he's wanting to justify himself because
the jews of course
thought they were the chosen race only
they were going to heaven
no one else everybody else you know
was yeah so
who is my neighbor and jesus answering
said
and i like the way he does this isn't it
amazing
it doesn't get into an argument it tells
a story
but the story is so amazing
a certain man went
down from jerusalem
to jericho now martin
you have to be very careful when you go
down from jerusalem
to jericho jericho was a cursed city
and the man who was to rebuild it was to
be cursed
yes even from his oldest to his youngest
yeah
he will set up the gates with the eldest
and uh lay the foundation with the
oldest
and sit and the gates with his youngest
so it was a cursed
city so this is a this is a very
very important principle
a certain man it's very non-descript
yeah it's not a brother
it's not a neighbor a neighbor
it's anybody anybody
a certain man includes the whole of
humanities
went down from jerusalem to jericho
now how many of us
went down from
the heavenly ideal
[Music]
to the cursed city
all of us qualify
yes definitely all right so you're a
certain man
yep do i qualify i'm sure you do
absolutely
i'm a certain man i went down
from the high calling that god had for
humanity
to the very depth of degradation
depth of degradation nothing
was to remain of that city it's a type
of the destruction of the
end of the world right
and there he fell amongst thieves
now what did they rob you of
the everlasting life they robbed you of
everything including your everlasting
life
right and uh the devil was a liar from
the beginning
and he stole you from christ
yeah so you ended up amongst thieves
when you went down
and they stripped him of his ramen
christ righteousness when you go down
from jerusalem to jericho that's the end
of your robe of righteousness right
so all of humanity had been stripped of
their reignment
when they fell amongst these thieves
that robbed them of the righteousness of
christ we must be very careful the
scripture
as this question says this person
noticed that throughout scripture
there's this constant play upon going
up and going down and that's why i
thought you know this parable
breathes ah explains it so beautifully
so all of us are in this position we
have
been stripped of our robes of
righteousness we have
fallen amongst thieves and we are
wounded
what kind of wound do we have that's
spiritual emotional yes
it's a deadly wound it's a wound that
will lead to death
right yep so we are wounded to death
and departed leaving him half dead
so basically that's our condition
walking around on this planet
wounded to death naked stripped of
all righteousness living amongst liars
and
thieves and we're half dead
on the way to being totally dead
and by chance
you know when i read the scripture i
always have to smile
because in the scripture nothing is by
chance no
nothing absolutely nothing whether it's
bad or whether it's good if it's bad god
permitted it
if it's good god introduced it right yes
so by chance there came
what down down he didn't go up
no a certain priest that way now
what condition should this priest have
been in uh
enlightened an enlightened one what's he
doing going down
it's not a good thing so how do we know
that he's a down priest and not a real
up priest
because when he saw him he passed by on
the other side
so he was a pharisee he didn't do what
he he said
thank god i'm not like that piece of
dirt over there
so maybe this man is a druggie or an
alcoholic
or this that than the other
and he took one look at him
and said no that's that's not going to
work for me
i think i told the story once where i
was preaching in a church
and this gang that had been breaking up
churches remember yes came in with their
chains and they were going to
beat everyone up and break everything up
and uh i said come in there's lots of
place in the first place and the way
they sat you know
[Laughter]
looking at me it was it was amazing
and uh one of them was baptized the
leader
so you know we the way we treat people
is very important
and when he saw him he passed by on the
other side and this is the condition of
the world that we have today
some people think that you know
they have arrived and
they look down on all of these people
so i've had so many of those situations
where people come into the church
or a young girl comes into the church
and there are so many rings through the
nose and through the lip
and through the ears and through the
eyebrows and
through the tongue that there's hardly
room to put another staple
and people look at this and they say
what is the
god came in here no into the church
right
when in actual fact when such a person
comes into the church
it's a cry for help that's what it is
and how do you look at it do you look at
it with
disdain or do you
see it as a cry for help
what did that demoniac
say when christ stood before him
i'm not worthy i'm not go away yeah go
away
but in actual fact he was actually
screaming help me exactly
right because he kept running towards
him
so this is how the world
experiences christianity in many many
cases or religions in general
and likewise a levite
when he was at the place came and looked
on him
and passed by on the other side this is
the sad state
of the church
if you think that you have arrived and
you are on a better and a higher level
then you have forgotten where you came
from
and you've gone from up to down
so my question to you
this fellow this nondescript
individual is he any better
off than this priest or this levite
no they're also going down they're all
down
they actually at this stage all of them
are lost
it's a very sad state of affairs what
does that tell you about the state of
the church
yeah has to qualify for the same
it qualifies for the same so we have to
ask ourselves
are we on the way down
or are we on the way up
and the way we treat people
will often be an indication of whether
we
are on the way up or whether we are on
the way down right yes
but a certain samaritan
now this is a very fascinating portion
again it is not specific
it says a certain samaritan
now they were the most despised of all
people
in fact if they wanted to insult you
beyond
measure they would call you a samaritan
and they actually said to jesus you are
a samaritan
that is like the worst swear word
for which you will go to jail
these days or be incarcerated okay
so a certain samaritan as he journeyed
came where he was this
broken person now it's very important
here martin
he didn't go down the samaritan
he didn't go up he didn't go down
he was on a journey
yeah he was on a journey he had a
mission
he was on a journey now when you go on a
journey are you on a mission yes
all right so this samaritan we don't
know his identity at this stage
but he's not going down
or up he's on a mission
and he came to where he was
that would give you a clue did someone
else go on a mission to meet us where we
were
yes jesus all right
and when he saw him
he had compassion on him did the levite
have compassion
no had disdain right yes
the priest same same thing
but this one who was on a mission
yeah and who was despised and who wanted
to meet him where he was
he had compassion and he went to him
and then he bound up his wounds
pouring in oil
and wine it's a very strange thing to do
right
yeah very strange all right so
he was wounded and we are all wounded
now the only way to heal these wounds
is with oil and wine
what's the oil early spirit okay
and the wine doctrine huh
so what was the healing bomb
that could save this man's life
bringing him closer to god through
the teachings of the word of the word
and the
working of the holy spirit okay
and then he brought him to an inn
now this is so beautiful
because he brought him to an inn just
cast your mind
to your old life what did you do in an
inn
you eat and drink aha
and you're merry right you eat and drink
and i marry in an inn
so when you're hungry and you see an inn
that's where you go
so he brought him to an inn and took
care of him
that's a very strange place to bring
someone
very strange so
how did he bring him to the inn on his
own beast
on his own beast
in other words he used his own
implements of work and burden
to bring him to the inn
now this has implications for
a little bit later now let's go to verse
and on the morrow
when he departed
he took out two pence
and gave them to the host and he said
unto him
take care of him and whatsoever thou
spendest more when i come again i will
repay thee
that is the most loaded
verse in this parable
and we need we need to discuss this in
some
more detail and on the morrow
that's the next day yes so we're dealing
with daisy
when he departed he took out
two pens
and gave them to the host and said unto
him
take care of him and whatsoever thou
spend us
more when i come i will repay thee so in
this
inn it was not only a place where you
sleep
like a hotel or a restaurant or a place
where you can have a drink
it was also a hospital yes
because they had to take care of him
right they had to
get him well he was he was still in a
state
no no this is a church
so the lord disguises it here and he
says
basically i took him to my church
and i said to them take care of him
this man is wounded yeah so who comes to
this church
people that are wounded
so why is it martin that when we see the
wounded walk into the church and say oh
brother what's this coming into the
church why is that so
because we are like the levite and the
priest we've become like the levite and
the priest so we've
not gone up we've certainly gone down
right yes
where did the lord go and look for his
people
highways and byways why did why do you
go to the highways and byways
because that's where the wounded are aha
so he went and he picked up this man
and he said to him you take care of him
until i come because he says over here
take care of him and whatever thou
spendeth more when i come again
i will repay thee
what is this when i come again the
second coming
so he departed and then he said i will
come again
and if you take care of him
and you spend anything more in other
words you do
more than is actually required of you
i will repay you how
by giving you crowns everlasting life
ah isn't this beautiful but here's
another
another clue and i'm on very dangerous
ground now
and i'll get into trouble again but
by now martin that is my second name
so let's let's venture a little
bit of uh daring and discuss something
else here
so he came on a journey he was on a
mission
and his mission was
that one yeah and he gave him oil
and wine and he gave him wine he gave
him the truth
and he gave him the holy spirit and he
gave him care
and he gave him love and he put him on
his
own beast of burden which means that
he walked he didn't sit on it
right yeah he walked next to it
so the king of kings put me
on the beast of burden and walked next
to it
and carried me he carries you yeah he
carried me
to his church and then he said take care
of him
until i come again and here's some money
for you
two pence now a penny
was one day's wages for
a roman soldier
one day's wages
so for how many days did he give him
money two days
he gave him money for two days that's
very interesting martin
two days of money now
why didn't he give him three days or
four days is two days wages enough
to take care of someone who's really
wounded
well it had to be if he gave him only
two two days
wages then it would have been enough yes
because the lord never makes a mistake
right
now now martin the pioneers of the
adventist church
they believed in the cosmic week yes
right where a day stands for a thousand
years
now today that doctrine is not very
popular
and i believe that in the spirit of
prophecy
we see that
that author also i believe believed in
the cosmic week
but seeing that it's not so popular
today because
you know evolution has really messed up
our concept of time
and uh to think in terms of
a period of 6 000 years
is something that is highly problematic
to many a mind in the world today
and when i was in the world it was
equally problematic for me
but uh if we were to allow
ourselves the luxury of speculation
let's say that way yeah well
then two days wages
in terms of the cosmic week would be how
much time
two thousand years two thousand years
and if that is so then
whatever way we calculate it without
mentioning a day
or an hour or a year
it must be very close yes would you
agree
i agree okay
so well let's continue and leave it
there
but it is tempting to think like that
take care of him and whatever thou spend
us
more when i come again i will repay thee
which now of these three thinkest thou
was neighbor unto him that fell amongst
the thieves
and he said he that showed mercy on him
then said jesus unto him go
and do thou likewise
so the only one who can demonstrate to
us
what it means to love your neighbor
as yourself is jesus
did jesus die for
the converted yes
did he die for the unconverted yes
did he die for the despised
did he die for zacchaeus yes
he died for did he say today
salvation has come to your house and fat
little zacchaeus climbed down from the
tree
did zacchaeus expect it no
no it's the last thing you ever expected
right
correct that the pharisees expected nope
they were
horrified right they were horrified
so this is an amazing story so
where do we get our cue as to what it
means to love your neighbor
from jesus okay now
let me just rephrase this again
what did he give him what did he put on
him
oil and wine i see
on the most despised
he put oil and wine on this
person that was wounded in this world
what is our job to do the same to do
likewise
to do likewise and to take him to the
end yes
how by giving him the oil and the wine
but then carrying him there on your own
beast so
you carry him there you must carry him
there
and you must use everything
that you have at your disposal
in other words your hospitality
your vehicles your whatever it takes
whatever means is in your ability
take him to the end now
some inns are
you know wonderful to take people to and
some inns
are rather scary places
so these days sometimes the inn can even
be your own home
yes wherever you can give him
oil and and wine
and bread because that's what you will
also get at the end
correct and binding up of the wounds yes
there you must take him evangelism
is the high calling of god
and we have to partake
in this and if you bring this message
of salvation will you have enemies
definitely definitely right most of the
time
the pharisee and the priest and the
levite will become your enemies
they will be the most problematic in
many cases right
sometimes one wishes they would just
walk by on the other side of the road
but
sometimes they decide that no this is
worth interfering with right
so yes it is a it is an interesting
question
do we go up or do we go down
so when we go down let us not go down
let us go on a journey
yes let's just go on a mission
let's go on a mission to find the
brokenhearted
and carry them up and carry them up
to jerusalem and
put them in amen thank you so much
let's have a look at another question
and this is first a statement of this
person and the question will come a
little bit later
i've watched many of your programs over
the years
i especially love all the ones that
expose roman catholicism
for what it truly is i was raised in a
strict
superstitious catholic household and was
indoctrinated by the roman catholic
church in school for 12 years
as you know it takes a lot of work
to undo what was so easily poured into
my little sponge of a mind for all those
years
my question is what is meant by binding
and loosing
which jesus said to the apostles you
know how the roman catholic church says
that it has
to do with christ jesus giving peter
and his successors in brackets other
popes and priests the power to your
confession
and dole out penance according to
matthew 18
18 and matthew 8 16 19. now
i can concur with this
question because i was in exactly the
same position
and some people say that i have a
vendetta
because of whatever happened to me in my
life
i can categorically say i have no
vendetta whatsoever
but to me the very worst thing
is to be deceived
deception is worse
than outright unrighteousness
i always use an example when i talk
about these issues martin
and you being a married man tell me
which one to you
is your wife says to you
martin i cannot stand you
this is just a parable
[Laughter]
your wife says to you martin i cannot
stand you in fact i
hate everything about you you
disgust me you live your life i live my
life
you don't come near me i don't want to
know you
i despise you
and then a few weeks later you find out
she's having an affair
it probably hurt you she's after all
your wife
but somewhat expected it's sort of
expected
but let's take the other scenario
she says i love you the most wonderful
thing that has ever happened to me
she's loving and kind and cuddling
and everything that your heart desires
and then you find out that all this time
she's been having an affair with someone
else
which one of the two scenarios is worse
definitely the second
definitely well
that's how i felt when i found out
what catholicism was all about
because it is based on deception
and the bible says be careful lest
anyone deceive you
and deception is so much worse
than blatant apostasy
at least if i were to become a member of
the church of satan
yes you'll know where i know exactly
where i'm standing
right and i will have absolutely no
excuse
but the tactic of the devil that is the
most
successful and he he tried it in eden
and he
succeeded his deception
right so yes i can concur
now why is it that we find these verses
in the bible
that roman catholicism can latch onto
and say but we have this authority
the first thing i would like to say to
whoever
asked the question is
first study all the criteria of the
bible
and see whether rome is in harmony with
them or in disharmony with them
and if the answer is she's not in
harmony with them
then how can she in spite of the
disharmony
claim the authority right correct
it doesn't make any sense so that's the
first point
if there are points where
rome disagrees or contradicts the
scriptures
then she cannot be the authority of god
upon this earth so this question is what
is meant by
binding and losing and why do they say
that this authority is vested
in the popes well let's look at matthew
chapter 16
and look at the confession of peter
where he confesses jesus as the christ
when jesus came into the coasts of
caesarea
philippi he asked his disciples saying
whom do men
say that i the son of man
am and they said
some say thou art john the baptist
some elias and others
jeremiah's or one of the prophets
so they believed that one of these had
been resurrected
how they could believe that it's john
the baptist resurrected
no one can really understand because
they were contemporaneous
but maybe some didn't know jesus before
they knew john was dead and he was
another preacher that was as powerful or
more powerful
maybe he was resurrected whatever
and he said unto them but whom say ye
that i am and he is plural so he's
talking to his disciples
and he's saying who do you say i am
and simon peter answered and said
thou art the christ the son
of the living god
that is his confession
of faith and jesus
answered and said unto him blessed art
thou
simon bard jonah for flesh and blood has
not revealed it unto thee but my father
which is in heaven
and i say also unto thee that thou art
peter and upon this rock i will build my
church
and the gates of hell shall not prevail
against it
so now you have two options
either peter is the rock
or his confession that he just made
is the rock upon which the church stands
now peter means pebble yes it doesn't
mean rock rock no
but throughout the scriptures christ
is referred to as the rock so
can it be that peter has now become a
rock
even though he's designated the pebble
or does it mean that the commission or
the confession that he has over here
that thou art the christ
the son of the living god is the basis
and foundation of the christian church
that's the first point secondly you then
have to ask yourself
did peter ever claim to be the leader of
the church
yeah you have to ask a question but no
he didn't no he didn't
in fact in the first council the one who
stood up
and gave the summation of what was
discussed
was james yes jesus brother did he ever
take uh worship or
obeyance to him no what did he say to
cornelius
who was a centurion
get up yeah i'm only a man okay
i'm the same as you so he didn't take
the prerogatives
as the roman catholic church claims
so they are deceptive by applying the
great confession
to themselves when it can only apply
to christ yes this that is rather
serious
and then it continues and it says i will
give unto thee the keys of the kingdom
of heaven
and whatsoever thou shalt bind on earth
shall be
bound in heaven and whatsoever thou
shalt loose
on earth shall be loosed in heaven
what does that mean well
the church of god
on earth is the highest authority
representing heaven and in this church
certain decisions can be made for
example who
may be included and who may be
excluded or must be excluded
and if you read the new testament you
will see
that paul and other writers tell you
exactly how to deal
with brethren or sisters
that have left the path with such one to
not even eat
for example or paul says can you not
judge the smallest things
don't you know that one day you will
judge even angels
so the church has a certain
capacity and a certain authority on
earth
no one can forgive sins other than god
the bible is very clear on this issue
they wanted to stone jesus
because he had said that he can forgive
sins
and they said no one can forgive sins
but god
but a church can put you under center
so let's say martin i find out tomorrow
that you have been
living in adultery
then the church would have to put you on
the center
yes and you probably wouldn't be sitting
there
to get you back in line you have to get
back in line
and if the same happened to me the same
would apply
and the church has that authority the
church has the authority
to bind you or to loose you
and if they find that your lifestyle is
not
in accordance with your profession
then they have the right to tell you
don't call yourself what you call
yourself when you are not prepared to
live
according to the standards which you
promised when you were baptized
right yeah it comes back to that
anointing of the ear and the thumb and
the
toe very good point very good point so
this is the only authority that the
church has
uh can the church misuse this authority
does it sometimes misuse this absolutely
yes
so it cuts both ways right
then charged to his disciples that they
should tell no man
that he was jesus the christ
because his time had not yet come right
1 corinthians 6 verse 2 says do ye not
know that the saint shall
judge the world and if the world shall
be judged by you or you know
are you unworthy to judge the smallest
matters
this has nothing to do with forgiveness
this has to
do with basic principles if you take for
example
the many scandals that are in the world
today
isn't that the church that decides then
that this person
should be excluded from the ministry yes
right
so if you if you have
the terrible things that are happening
in churches today
and sin is everywhere
there is no one institution on this
earth at the moment
that stands in perfect purity
by the fruits you must judge them so
one rotten apple doesn't make the whole
basket
rotten thank you for that discussion
let's go to another question yes the
bible says that all men have sinned and
fallen short of the glory of god
including enoch and elijah how is it
that those men were translated directly
into heaven
you know modern i think we answered that
in a previous what's up didn't we yes
yeah
because we spoke about the post data
checks
that's it remember so
these individuals enoch
and elijah were examples
they were also as it were post dated
checks they were promises
of a fulfillment so as we spoke about
enoch we said
that enoch was the message to the
anti-deluvian world
that those who follow god
will be translated to heaven
and elisha was the promise to the
post-diluvian world
yes after the flood that
there will be a people that will be
translated without seeing death so they
are the promise
for the very last generation
now the other one was moses
moses had died and he had a resurrection
so he is the promise to those that will
die
in christ yes that they also will be
resurrected
now this takes us martin to the the
mount of transfiguration yes
and when jesus was there and he started
to shine like the sun
the two individuals that appeared to him
were
elisha and moses aha
because moses also had died
and had a resurrection so there were two
examples standing on either side of
jesus
moses who had died and had a
resurrection again
a guarantor of those that would die
and be resurrected and the other one
had never seen death so he was the
guarantor for those
that would not die but would be changed
in the moment in a twinkling
of an eye at the last trump so
both of them were there but there are
two other aspects
as well why those two were there because
moses stands for the law the torah
the bible and elijah
stands for the prophets so to the law
and to the testimony to the law and to
the prophets
if they speak not according to this word
they have
no light in them so
these are the guarantees
that if you follow the law
that's the bible the torah and if you
listen to what the prophet said to say
then you will like them
one day stand beside christ
in heavenly places that is the promise
but
you know martin let's bring this to our
day
if god chose a prophet
to warn the people of god
before the flood of
a coming calamity yes
how much more so would he not choose
also a prophet in the last days
to enlighten the people as to
exactly how these things will
develop yeah and to help
gravel through all the murky
nonsense that's being told out there and
the distortions
and then if you look in the bible you
have this promise
that the last church those that keep the
commandments
and hold to the testimony and the
testimony
is the spirit of prophecy according to
revelation 19
there will be this prophetic gift and
the bible says
believe in the prophets yes
right then you will be established
so all of these things come together
so jesus is basically saying
in the on the mount of transfiguration
where elisha was there
believe in your prophets and believe in
your word
and the two have to be in harmony to the
law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word they have no
light in them
so that is why these people were in
heaven
but imagine now
if jesus had failed yes
at the cross what would have happened to
enoch
elisha and moses
and moses they would have had to come
back they would have had to die
because the wages of sin is death and
they had
all like everyone else yes sinned
because the bible says they were of like
passions
right correct moses had murdered
he'd murdered an egyptian moses had
struck the rock more than once
so they would have had to depart
and go into an eternal grave
just a question that also pops up quite
often
enoch did he write the book of enoch
well the book of enoch is an apocryphal
book there are some very interesting
things
but you know the devil is a master at
writing interesting things
morals and dogma to many is a very
interesting book
but it's a channeled book yeah and
this is a very important point god never
channels information never
there's no such thing as automatic
writing no
god inspires but he doesn't bypass
your mind and your intellect and your
capacity
he will help you he will guide you with
his spirit
but what you saw you write in
your own words now the book of enoch
being an apocrypha for book
and never having been part of the canon
is therefore excluded from the canon
and like all apocryphal books should be
treated that way
and to go and study it to see
what you can glean is like trying
to study the book of satan in order to
see what you can learn about god
thank you very much what was the first
light that was created in genesis 1
verse 3
as it's not the sun moon or stars that
were created in genesis 1 verse 14 to
19.
i once gave a lecture on the big five
questions of life
you know where do we come from why are
we here etc
why is the world in such a state why is
it such a mess
what's the solution
and one of the questions that arises
therein
is where do we come from either we come
from evolution by an evolutionary
process
or we were created yes okay
where does this world come from either
it came by a cosmic
explosion as explained by the jesuits
and swallowed by science hook line and
sinker
or we believe that god created
so i went into the question of
quantum physics and matter
now the bible says god is light
god is light so what is god
well god is light now so the first
question you have to ask yourself if god
is light does he need a sun a moon or
stars to create light
no no he's light so when he comes he's
going to
outshine the sun right yes yes so in
other words
he's brighter than the sun or the moon
or the stars he is light if you go into
the question what
is light light consists of photons
now the question in in physics is
is light matter
or is it a wave
yes and they thought that life
light was only a wave
but light actually has an impact if you
take a picture
then the light strikes
some receptor that records that light
has been struck now
in the old days you used to have a film
in a camera
and it had a surface that when light
struck it
it left an impact mark and that became
the picture when you developed it right
so it had matter
so somebody came up with the bright idea
to
shine light through a
tiny hole and
you fire the light and it goes through
the hole
and it leaves its impact on the other
side
on a photographic plate for example
so light is acts like matter
but then they came up with a bright idea
of making
two holes and shooting that same
particle of light
and it went through both holes now
that's impossible
you can't go through both holes and if
you add a thousand holes they would go
through all the holes
so in other words it acted like a wave
and not
like matter but it has an impact
therefore it is
matter but it's not matter so
basically when you boil down the
question
is what does it consist of
and the scientists in the world will
tell you
that the big bang was created when
nothing exploded and created
everything it sounds almost like
and god created everything
out of nothing exactly so here's the
bottom line martin
quantum physics will tell you that
when you take it down to its lowest
denominator
then you end up with nothing so that
cosmic egg
in the big bang theory according to
science
consisted of nothing
and nothing exploded and created
everything
which is the most nonsensical thing that
you can possibly imagine
but that is the very heart and essence
of science
now they say that the the believer in
the word of god
is nonsensical and an ignorant fool
because he believed that god created
everything out of nothing
but they believe the same thing same
thing right
and they've got much less that they can
explain
than we can through the bible exactly
and god
authenticates what he said by giving you
an accurate record of history
and then in case you don't believe that
it gives you an
accurate history of the future
uh i want to see the scientists do that
they've been very predictive lately in
the in the media
and many many things especially climate
change
and all of those and nobody really knows
what the final outcome is going to be
but god says what's going to happen
and so far in the 35 years
that i've been involved in christianity
having been an atheist as everybody
knows by now before
i can say that i have not been able to
fault
that book i haven't been able to fault
it
and in the beginning i really tried
and after the beginning i really had to
study because of all the questions that
people ask
and then they sometimes throw you a
curveball
and then you go and check it out and you
say well you know that wasn't a
curveball at all you could hit it out of
the park because the bible
you know explains itself and they would
they would come
out with all the contradictions in the
bible unbelievable this contradicts that
that contradicts this
and the times are different for the same
event and then you find out the one
is using hebrew time and the other one
is
using roman time and actually they're
exactly the same thing and so
you know the contradictions just became
less and less and less and less
and they do the same with the spirit of
prophecy 100 the same oh
they're constantly telling you where
it's wrong and then you go and study it
and you see we discussed the one the
other day
the sprinkling of the garments a simple
thing like that right
so where does this light come from god
is light he does not
need a source of light in order to say
let there be light amen
thank you so much i think we will
conclude with that for today
let's close with the word of prayer
heavenly father
thank you once again that you have
provided
so many answers in this good book
and if we were only to believe and
understand
then none of us need to be lost
because besides the word the greatest
teacher that has
ever ever existed
works through the holy spirit to impress
that word upon the mind
all that we need is an open mind
and a willing heart and even that
you provide we pray that you will
lead and guide all who want to know
what the scriptures teach and bring them
to that
final culmination when you come with the
clouds of heaven is my prayer in jesus
name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you